tous deux se trouvent sur ce libre
échange audio à faire de l'élevage de
créatures kawaii ces partis alors j'ai
absolument jamais joué à ce jeu je vais
découvrir avec vous mais le principal
est assez simple au regard de ce pot
mignon c'est petit jeu les la ola l'on
peut on peut être sur leur tête elles
ont l'air bien en liberté c'est pour ça
qu'on va les capturer alors il y en a un
petit peu dans notre base de départ ou
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je ne sais
pas alors en gros le but du jeu il me
semble c'est de faire un véritable
élevage de ces petites violet très
mignonne et très heureuse si leur fils
un poulet le beauf
oui [ __ ] a immédiatement plus et du
coup elle me pons quoi un deuxième pic
porte merde j'ai un respect sans faire
exprès pardon ces problèmes qui arrivent
donc là après avoir mangé mais petit jeu
les chenilles des pink floyd on va dire
les choses comme elles sont et c'est
ping plein dans cette machine la
regarder elles valent cette pièce d'or
donc je les envoie là dedans et hop ça
me donne cette pièce et ça nous fait
deux cent soixante dix huit pièces d'or
c'est de l'élevage kawaii en fait ce jeu
c'est génial alors vous avez appris les
choses fondamentales maintenant c'est
l'heure de sortir d'ici et d'explorer au
à tort c'est génial ce jeu là je vais
tout aspiré mordelles des carottes et
des haies des jeux les par bigné et est
ce que je me les plantes et les carottes
pour faire d'autres carottes et ouais
nous on pense au futur déjà je veux
faire l'élevage le plus zen of du monde
jamais à temps et l'enclos est trop
petit pour elle la france au bien-être
aussi des l'escrim un peu après ils ont
pas l'air bien compliqué mais bongo m
et comment cette nombreux alors écoutez
leur race faire des testicules encore
comme on dit dans le milieu la regarder
notre agent comilog mandat de ce
fantastique à sherman locked palpite
tout ce qui ne rapporte pas d'argent ne
m'importe peu remercions tout de suite l
aventure est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut trouver d'autres créatures capturés
c'est faut dire un mafieux c'est qu'est
en train de voler des animaux dans la
nature des espèces en voie de
disparition au des nouvelles créatures
lacoste l'iman large
ah merde ils sont trop gros l'a3 route
ou au plat on a eu un tapis slim cd mini
chiens ils sont trop mignons [ __ ]
alors là à mon goût on est totalement
des femmes là pendant cette vidéo tout
virilité est morte on était déjà morte à
la base mais alors si les problèmes
qu'on va voir ce sera pour les nourrir
comment faire un stock limité de
nourriture qui tue fleurs dehors toit du
nord regardez on a des espèces
différentes teintes on est bien là on
est bien allé ramasser elle évolué il a
évolué de tout coup après je pense que
nous répondre et tout temps dans une
cage devrait en mettre genre si c'est
les faire tous évolué
oh mon dieu ils sont spéciaux c'est des
lumières c'est des lucioles
il faut qu on aspire tous ses fruits la
ola là on va nourrir notre élevage
savent être fatale c'est quoi ça il
mange tout est faux ce bar et c'est la
nuit ok c'est devenu dangereux
regardez ils sont tous mangé par ses
trucs je vais vous sauvez venez avec moi
alors déjà on va faire là mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font en dehors lui aussi c'est
pas vrai ça alors on va nourrir eux la
les rares poussées vous tous
bon allez dégage en être capturés en
fait je suis fait avoir on va en
remettre dans la nature et on va faire
les vaches que de ceux qui sont un peu
plus rares selon liberté venez là ce ne
vous allez manger ce qui traîne dans ma
base bande de [ __ ] high up parfait
manger tous les enfants je vous nourrit
et puis quoi les laisse mauvais alors
regardez il y en a pas mal qui ont
grossi et attends je vais faire un test
lui on peut pas nourrir avec ça non
c'est du caca ça pour lui au live house
mahoudeaux des noms
[ __ ] mais je suis le piano bar la
planète revenez la volaille faucon a
d'autant que l'on est pas possible sinon
c'est l'heure de dormir en réalité ce
quiz indoor biba et passa toute la nuit
à travailler durement pour le bien
dur alerte pedobear bada on a donc ici
notre petit élevage aimé que des roses
ici on a fait un petit potager voilà on
a porté la carotte un petit peu comme ça
on a une source de nourriture toutes les
72 heures et ici on a fait un petit
poulailler voilà pour le moins avec des
poussins qui tournent sur eux-mêmes ils
savent pas trop pourquoi ils sont en vie
mais croyez moi ça reste utile plus tard
bref on va retourner explorer le monde
vaste qui nous entoure
oh il ya vu kaka qui vaut cher ça c'est
du caca qui vaut cher ça la plaindre aux
nounous là où il ya des petits poucets
il m'en faut ok on a chopé quelques
espèces et de quoi alimenter le
poulailler
on rentre squeeze n'avait aucune idée de
l'état dans lequel il allait retrouver
sa base au sommet gasquet photo matt
être mangé c'est pas pour son bordel
qu'est ce que vous foutez en dehors vous
là en fait ça à cause du gros il les
fait sauter à les dégager les enfants
merci d'être passé c'était cool
à bientôt alors on va résulte ce bordel
venez là mais n'ont échoué dans le
poulailler vous abusez un peu c'est lui
là qui fait chier mais je sais pas
comment le soigner
j'ai compris en veine le problème c'est
que j'aurais pas dû mélanger les espèces
dans le même enclos plus je vous l'avais
dit que j'aurais pas dû je ne peux plus
[ __ ] ça partait si bien et ça fini si
mal j'ai su le faire j'ai fait un choix
qu'on peut faire un incinérateur bas
comme ça je les prendrais jeu les
incinérer en fait vous voyez sont pas
malades fiction allaitent et ceux qui
bavent là comme celui que j'ai amené un
dehors comme un [ __ ] piquetage le rend
malade et je me débarrasse de lui je
suis vraiment fdp eu en fait c'est juste
des espèces spécial mais qui sont un peu
casse couilles
parce qu'ils sont grands ce qui fait que
du coup c'est ingérable par contre il
donne l'état bip leur télé tabbee pleure
ça se vend 15 allée lui les malades
comment je fais pour te soigner petit
gars on va faire un autre enclos juste à
côté dans lequel on va mettre juste les
gros les gros champ vous allez venir
avec moi et vous allez rester ici et là
normalement où ils me donnent des kaka
qui valent de l'or regarder aller
partout le fallait ce le respect mort il
son rôle ou à s'échapper seul assez
incroyable watts est devenu quoi au nom
pourquoi il est devenu méchant mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça vient la
salle o je me sacrifie pour mes bébés et
à la faute
je vous laisse les gars désolé a plus
pourquoi il ya un gros comme ça qui a
paru c'est quoi ce bordel
et tout cela qu en profite pour
s'échapper mais les [ __ ] quoi le
respect se faire bordel arrêtez de vous
échapper aux caissières de se coucher
une fois de plus ce quiz epasa
il ya dormir comme un gros fils de [ __ ]
voilà et sa femme travaille à sa place
bonjour bonjour avez vous bien dans mon
[ __ ] mais j'en ai marre mais tu elle
est ok maintenant j'en ai marre la cnra
thurella aux non non non pas ça en fait
je pense que ça donne ça quand je le
nourris mal et quand je tiens un
incinérateur hop ça dégage ces photos
tchèque tout ce qui s'est chargé brûle
que ce soit clair et jaffe tu vas brûler
on envoie les gentilles à 37,2 sur ce
livre est j'espère que ça vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas l'aimer comme
d'habitude moi ça m'a plu voilà alors
j'ai pas compris tous les mécanismes
exactement mais je sais qu'avec doit
venger certains trucs et pas d'autres
trucs et malheureusement je leur ai
donné ses autres trucs là à manger avant
de les chasser comme un égoïste parce
qu'ils étaient malades en tout cas c'est
un super jeu j'ai beaucoup aimé je
pensais pas mais j'ai beaucoup aimé il
en action anticipé donc je pense qu'il
aura plein de nouveaux contenus et que
ça va déchirer de plus en plus un vrai
plaisir cet élevage à l'instant t sa
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé le
show du monde portez vous bien en pis
oh